[Music]
hey friends so check it out uh fresh
today I just got a package from flow
toys which is lovely because I was
expecting this to show up for a couple
days yet and it is a thing that I'm very
very excited to explore it is the bridge
that will make the flowtoys app work
with my flow toys POI and be able to
program special things for them so
I am going to dive into these for the
first time with all of you Drex here
from drexfactor pulley sharing with you
the love of poi spinning and flow Arts
to benefit your body and brain and today
I'm going to be giving you my first
impressions of the flow toys app
programming with it and of course what
the results of that happen to be so
you're going to find out at the same
time I do but before we dive in I just
want to give a quick shout out to the
Friends of the channel big thanks to
dark monk fire Mecca flow fests flow
toys juggling calling pyro Terra light
toys spin balls and Ultra POI for
helping to make the videos on this
channel possible you can learn more
about all of these awesome companies and
the work that they're doing to support
flow artists like yourself by checking
out the links that I have down in the
description of this video and special
thanks to the non-business Friends of
the channel Lane machinski and Becca
becklenen thank you both so much for
supporting my channel my work and my
mission
all right so first things first let's
unbox this bad boy
[Applause]
all right so it looks like what we've
got here is we've got a series of
written instructions uh as well as a USB
power cable for the bridge itself which
uh comes in a little 3D printed package
here and I believe connects to this here
power bank all right so according to the
little handout here the first five steps
uh number one I gotta download The
flowtoys Connect app I already did that
it did that a few months ago uh number
two you gotta register your app account
also did that number three update your
prop firmware that I haven't done in a
little while so that I'm gonna have to
take care of today number four group
your props I think actually my POI are
already grouped and number five uh
instructions for using the bridge may
need to charge before use insert the
bridge
into the 3D printed case when your
bridge is on you'll see a red light
turning it off just means pulling the
power bank out of the case apparently or
excuse me I do not pull that all the way
out I just pull it far enough out that
the light turns out go to flowtoys
connect app on your mobile device to
find and connect your Bridge connect
your props and enjoy the app outstanding
let's start this off by seeing if this
has any kind of charge I'm going to plug
it in I want to plug this in in such a
way that the smaller USB port is going
to be uh on the same side of the little
insert area as this little 3D printed
kind of block here I'm going to give you
a close-up here so you can see that
yourselves let's let's see if it has any
charge to it first and foremost that is
a snug fit and I am terrified of
breaking the board so I'm going to go
really really really
gingerly here there we go hey and I've
got a red light Hallelujah all right now
to see if I can make this talk to my
phone so I'm in the app right now I am
scrolling down to
connect hey found a bridge and gonna hit
the little button that says Connect Now
now connected to the bridge via
Bluetooth outstanding all right so let's
see then what happens if I turn on one
of these POI wow
check that out that happened
automatically that's rad it says
unclaimed group
prop button 5x quickly do this one first
one two three four five cool connect now
says connected groups so it's giving me
several options here including uh choose
your prop type and uh more than one
always auto connect cool now I'm going
to hit save and I'm now connected to
these POI let me see if I can just turn
on freedom
hey look at that now I'm going to switch
to strobe mode
hey that worked out great so whichever
mode I happen to be in
um which in this case is strobe I can
scroll up some of the individual
settings for that mode and edit it a wee
bit I'm going to do that right quick
just to just to play around with it see
what happens oh this is cool so right
now I'm adjusting the Hue of the strobe
mode so I can go all the way through the
color spectrum that's handy there's
another slider here that just says
adjustment two I have no idea what that
does oh that's the speed of the strobe
that's cool one of the things that this
app does is
um you can download music onto it and
you can write a specific program into it
I think my next step here is that I'm
actually going to try and program a
little bit of the piece that I'm working
on and see if I can play it and catch it
on video for you all so it'll be listed
under shows here so big sad is the name
of the song that I'm choreographing to
so let me go ahead and pull that up
welcome to the showbuilder to adjust
slash edit a mode double tap on it to
move slash rearrangement mode hold on it
cool select the gear icon next to the
title to edit music and show length
that's helpful uh so I've got the the
music set in here already let me see if
I if this works by hitting insert cool
it does that was fairly intuitive
actually I'm going to go with air
because that's cool colors oh and what a
coincidence it also pulled up that mode
on the POI as I'm editing cool so that's
where I want to trim it going to select
the thing and uh looks like the tools
are fairly intuitive so I'm going to hit
that little scissors Mark and as I'd
hoped that cut it right at the playhead
so now I'm going to trash trying to
eliminate that one clip so I'm getting
the options of replace with empty space
expand from the right expand from the
left slide everything left oh that's
helpful so I'm just going to replace it
with empty space alright so next up I'm
going to go ahead and
add a mode that is going to add some
warmer colors into this and give us a
little bit of action for this next
section so I'm going to go ahead and
insert it playhead oh I can zoom in
that's super helpful we're going to swap
out for another mode oh replace that's
helpful to have there oh wait I think
the mode I want is blue blazer I bet you
anything is blue blazer sure enough that
was the mode all right so now the
challenge is I've got to expand this out
so that it hits
right at the edge I wish that it would
like lock into place when editing that
would be nice
there we go perfect and I'm going to add
in another mode here I'm going to stick
in spirit that'll be fun
so that right there I'm going to trim
delete expand from the right
so I think I want to have something
that's a warmer color you know what I
think I'm going to go with rainbow here
yeah rainbow sounds good so rainbow goes
in cool so I think I'm going to add in
one more mode I think I'm going to put
in sunset on this one
all right well that takes us to nearly a
minute so I'm going to go ahead and uh
say we're good for my testing purposes
here so I guess just some brief thoughts
about this part of the editing process
more more or less this is pretty
intuitive I like how smoothly it's going
I like that when I go to the insert page
it's really easy for me to see the
different modes that I want to add in
I also like that the interface for like
expanding out different pieces is is and
and Contracting different pieces and
deleting and cutting different pieces is
is pretty intuitive couple things that
like are a little bit rough number one
is that in the app itself the kind of
preview of the mode it looks like it's
centered around what uh the vision POI
would be doing with these modes rather
than what the capsules would be
displaying that's a little bit confusing
the only other note I have here is that
the magnetic timeline thing where it
like automatically locks you to the end
of a different clip
a little little bit hit or miss it
worked a couple times in here but there
were a couple times when it didn't work
as well and the other thing is is that
whenever there's a mode switch I'm
noticing that one of the POI switches
like about a half a second before the
other one and you know having a half a
second delay between mode changes can
definitely be a thing that like takes
you off the beat but I guess we'll all
find out together right so so how about
I go ahead and set up my uh Studio here
and record myself performing this and uh
see what the results are and we can take
it from there all right so the theory
here is that I'm using my camera
settings for capturing Trails so I am
shooting at 60 frames per second with my
shutter speed at 1 60th of a second if
you do not understand any of those words
at all don't worry I'm going to include
a link to a video that I've done showing
how I do my trails that will explain all
of it alright so one thing I'm realizing
would be super useful is to have like a
countdown so it would basically give
like a three two one and then the music
starts alright so I'm just gonna hit the
play button and go into places as soon
as I can
okay so after take one there's a couple
things that uh jump out to me that I
hadn't thought of before one of which is
that the mode that I'm starting with I
think it's air is
um acceler accelerometer reactive in a
way that I didn't actually want uh that
section of the choreo to be so I'm going
to need to replace that mode the other
thing being that the POI are a little
bit dimmer than I was hoping so I think
I'm going to try and adjust the
brightness of them to Max that out so
let me take all take care of all that
right quick and do another take of this
[Music]
I am still concerned about the
brightness of the POI so I'm going to
Monkey around with the lighting settings
here to see if I can get things darker
and get the POI to stand out a little
bit more
all right cool well let's go ahead and
bring that into my editing program and
see how that all turned out okay so I
have officially edited all five takes
that I took and I have some thoughts I
think that some of the cues that I
thought I was looking for in the music I
was a little bit off of but you know
it's by doing uh some of this editing
that you can spot those things I will
definitely say that adding trails to
footage is one of those things that
um is very very humbling in terms of
seeing moments when you try and do a
plane break that is not as clean as you
think it is that's going to require some
work on my part as I'm rehearsing this
piece it's become clear to me in
watching this that
um just the spirit mode doesn't really
work terribly well for doing Trails it's
so dim that the only way I can pull
Trails off of it is if
um the lighting of everything else is so
incredibly low that I lose an enormous
amount of color information on myself as
well as the background I can perhaps see
a use for it as being like something to
throw in there if I momentarily do not
want Trails on my footage that's an
interesting idea I will also say like
just in terms of the user experience of
using the app to run this show
um one thing that I really really wish
were different is the play button is so
teeny tiny that pretty much every single
uh take that I did
um I would hit the wrong spot at first
and
um that made life kind of difficult for
getting started but the good news is is
that the interface is really intuitive
um I think that it does all the things
that I could ask it to do yeah good
first impressions and of course if you
are interested in seeing where this goes
with future drafts I'm going to be
shooting a formal video of this piece uh
near the beginning of June and I'm
really really hoping that I will have it
released the final version of it by the
end of June so keep your eyes peeled for
now however I'm going to share with you
uh the best take that I got today and I
hope you enjoy watching it as much as I
enjoyed putting it together
thank you
[Music]
foreign
do you have the flowtoys app and Bridge
what has been your experience using them
leave me a comment and let me know and
if you got anything out of this video
please make sure to like comment share
and subscribe to help other people find
it and of course to help my channel grow
foreign
this video would not be possible we're
not for the kind support of all of these
lovely people right here these are my
flow patrons over on patreon they and
the people listed down in the
description helped to make this video
and all the videos on this channel
possible thank you one and all for your
very generous support and if you out
there watching are not currently
supporter but you would like to become
one you can do that by heading on over
to patreon.com directs factorpoi and
signing up there you can get access to a
whole host of awesome rewards but even
better than that you'll be helping me
out in my mission to bring POI spinning
and flow Arts to the whole wide world so
go check that out please and thank you
and if you'd like to see some of my
other product reviews associated with
flow Arts based equipment I will go
ahead and include a link to a playlist
of those videos down in the description
as well as up here on screen if you're
watching on YouTube also the YouTube
algorithm thinks that you might like
this top video here because it's popular
among other viewers of my channel so
maybe give that a look as well thanks so
much for watching make sure to get out
to flow today and I'll see the new video
real soon
peace